see a lot of drunk people people trying
to jump in the canal people have got in
the canal attempted to kill themselves
the worst thing you hear is when you
hear someone's on top of the building
[Music]
[Music]
so just finished in Leith I'm on the way
home from station grabbing a coffee or
some food Daniel ready for the night
shift my second job I joined the Angels
because I spend quite a lot time in the
in the village and I saw them doing
their work my routine goes into Virgil
art one of our members was punched and
quite badly and the village angels
weren't helped him so a friend got
involved through that and he got me
involved and I've been doing it for
about two and a half years now so it's a
really good way of being out in the
village on a Friday night but without
getting drunk because you play rugby on
this afternoon happy bug helps end the
calorie burn off as well along along
with the 17,000 steps that we have
returned and I think Louise if you do
first aid and only if you do crisis but
yeah let's go I think the angels are
really good because there are example of
our community of the LGBT community
helping itself and helping its members
when they need it most
I think the village is quite a special
place it's a safe haven for lots of
people lots of LGBT people who go there
so I think something like this is really
important to look after this specific
place because it's it's it is special to
the community knowing that people are
out there to help you I think that's
what is so important we'd had a radio
call to something going on there eagle
we looked up obviously saw the person
the person was stood on the wrong side
of a barrier and I think the fourth
floor it's quite high up we were never
in spoke to the police sergeant and said
look we know that person would you like
us to go and go up and talk the sergeant
came up with us to angels myself and
another shift lead went up when we did
begin to guess slowly closer he he was
then standing up and and being quite
agitated he was quite clearly
intoxicated as well I think I think the
intention was was clear that he did he
wasn't telling to end his life
he had a lot of things he wanted to talk
about a lot of things he wanted to want
to support with and that's what we were
trying to make sure he'd come back and
get that support rather than
and finish it there and then when she
gone back over the barrier and we agreed
that you know we come back to the office
with us since I have seen him and he
came and gave me a hug which is which is
really nice and not sure he understood
why he gave me a huggie he knew who we
were he knows that the village angels
are there for him and whether it's
someone imitate in particular or nice
it's all about the Angels as a whole I
came to the police briefing so we just
get an overview of what's going on in
the village who the key contacts are so
the sergeant that covers the village and
also the inspector that covers the city
so we get their contact details to talk
to them if we need them and obviously
just any information they want to give
us about missing people or any
particular big events things are live so
this is the kit we carry carry every
weekend pocket mask general first-aid
kit and this is our newest piece of kit
as well so defibrillator so we carry
this on every shift a throw rope so
obviously you operate near the canal a
lot some for blankets so keep your warm
in cold weather so yeah I think that the
verge is a place that you do have lots
of different people going there so there
are a lot of gay men that go there but a
lot of also lesbian women and there's
also a lot of trans people it's about
interacting with everybody we help
anybody weather and also lots of
straight people come to the villages
either other to support our LGBT friends
or they come for a night out or hen
parties is often the thing that we see
and we help everybody in an individual
way probably
be turned up yeah
do you do that yeah two seconds
[Music]
there's a - two girls and they'd been
attacked by another another punter one
who had a cooked a lip
the other one had a brooch that had
quite a big bump so thought best to
assess them there make sure there's
nothing particularly wrong with them and
then bring them to they behaving they
can wait for either an ambulance or the
police to rise take a statement from
them I think ultimately we need more
volunteers we need as many people who
are willing and who are able and also
enthusiastic to do the to do the role
that are brilliant ears do and obviously
of course it always comes down to money
as well we need money for equipment
money for the things we hand out the
plasters the foil blankets and for those
big-ticket items things like the
defibrillator we always need more of
those to make sure we can do the job
that we want to be able to do thinking
inside Manchester the angel should grow
I'd love to see it in London I love to
see it and Birmingham other big cities
with with gay porters and LGBT quarters
so that's what I'd hope and I think
hopefully if they ever want any help I'm
sure the Angels will be hit more than
happy to go and go up and help them
[Music]
you